what i want to do in this video is use
all of our powers all of our knowledge
of trig functions and trig identities in
order to figure out given all the
information that we have here in order
to figure out the length of this yellow
line this point this line that or the
segment that goes from here
to here and encourage you to pause the
video and think about it before before i
work through it
so i'm assuming you've had a go at it
and in doing that you might have
realized that okay this line that's one
of the light that's one of the sides of
this
right triangle that i have right over
here
and we've given this we're given this
alpha and beta but if we consider the
combined angle if we consider the
combined angle alpha plus beta then this
side right over here we can just take
out our traditional trig functions so
our sohcahtoa definition
of the basic trig functions and we know
that sine is opposite over hypotenuse so
if we're considering alpha plus beta
this angle right over here opposite over
hypotenuse that's going to be this
length over the hypotenuse which is one
so sine of alpha plus beta is going to
be this length right over here so that
seems interesting so let me write that
down
sine
of
alpha plus beta
sine of alpha
plus beta
plus
beta
is essentially what we're looking for
sine of alpha plus beta is this length
right over here sine of alpha plus beta
it's equal to the opposite side that
over the hypotenuse well the hypotenuse
is just going to be equal to one so it's
equal to this side
so another way of phrasing the exact
same problem that we first tried to
tackle is how do we figure out the sign
of alpha plus beta
and if if you're familiar with with your
trig identities something might be
jumping out at you that hey we we know a
different way of expressing sine of
alpha plus beta we know that this thing
is the same thing
as
we know it's the same thing as the sine
of alpha
plus a sine of alpha times the cosine
of beta
plus
the other way around the cosine of alpha
cosine
of alpha
plus or times the sine of beta times
the sine of beta let me draw a line here
so we don't get confused
so if we're trying to figure this out
and we know that this can be
re-expressed this way it all boils down
to can we figure out what sine of alpha
is cosine of beta cosine of alpha and
sine of beta
and when you look at this you see that
you actually can figure those things out
so let's do that
sine of alpha i'll write it over here
sine of alpha is equal to this is alpha
sine is opposite over hypotenuse so it's
0.5 over 1. so this is equal to 0.5
so that is 0.5
cosine of beta
cosine of beta this is beta cosine
is adjacent over hypotenuse so this is
beta the adjacent side is 0.6 over the
hypotenuse of 1. so it's 0.6
0.6
cosine of alpha
cosine of alpha adjacent over hypotenuse
it's square root of 3 over 2 over 1. so
that's just square root of 3
over 2.
so this is just
square root of 3
over 2 and then finally sine of beta
sine
of beta opposite over hypotenuse is
0.8
this is
and actually let me write that as i'm
going to write that as four-fifths just
so that
that's the same thing as 0.8 just
because i think it's going to make it a
little bit easier for me to simplify
right over here so what is all of this
equal to well this is going to be equal
to
0.5 times 0.6
this part right over here is 0.3
zero point three
and square root of three over two
times four fifths
well let's just multiply them well four
divided by two is two so it's two
squares of three over 5.
so this is equal to or so plus
2 square roots of 3
over 5. so this is essentially our
answer i i feel a little uncomfortable
having it in these two different formats
where i have a fraction here and have a
decimal here so let me just write the
whole thing as a as a rational
expression so 0.3 is obviously the same
thing as 3 tenths
3 tenths so that's the same thing as 3
over 10
plus
now this if i want to write it over 10.
this is the same thing as 4 square roots
of 3
over 10 and of course if we add these
two we are going to get
plus 4 square roots of 3
plus four square roots of three
all of that
over
over ten
and we are done